if you know one thing about the fall of
the Berlin Wall it might be this mr.
Gorbachev tear down this wall or this or
maybe these moments were huge in
unifying Berlin and undermining the
physical symbol of a divided Europe
during the Cold War but they don't top
this one the last few minutes of an
otherwise uneventful press conference on
November 9th 1989 as a phlebotomist
nothing Auslan Canon or Napoleon phone
for our sets unless on philosophy that's
minor
one particular it might not look like it
but this is the moment the Berlin Wall
became obsolete completely by mistake
[Music]
after the Allied powers defeated Nazi
Germany in World War two they divided
the country into four parts each
controlled by a separate power these
formed into two new countries in 1949
Democratic West Germany and Soviet
controlled communist East Germany
officially named the German Democratic
Republic or GDR through the 1950s West
Germany prospered as a free society and
industrious member of Europe and
hundreds of thousands of East Germans
began emigrating west in search of new
opportunities to stem the tide the gdr
erected a barrier along the inner German
border separating the two countries with
barbed wire guarded checkpoints and in
many places defensive measures like land
mines but there was a loophole in Berlin
and it goes back to when the four Allied
powers controlled Germany see even
though the German capital was well
inside the Soviet zone the Allies
divided control of it equally to match
the rest of the country and when East
and West Germany formed so did East and
West Berlin even as the inner German
border fortified Berlin had no physical
barrier dividing it East Germans could
simply walk or take public
transportation to the western part of
the city and travel freely from there
the island of West Berlin
become the staging point for the free
road to the west this brain-drain
took a huge toll on East Germany's labor
force by 1961 more than three and a half
million East Germans about twenty
percent of their population had fled to
the west the majority of which were
young and well-educated but the Berlin
loophole closed on August 13th 1961 when
the city woke up to East German soldiers
standing shoulder-to-shoulder along the
invisible line dividing East and West
Berlin unannounced
they began unrolling kilometers of
barbed wire through the middle of the
city they were building the Berlin wall
by break until no contact but a friendly
wave travel out of East Berlin became
strictly regulated no one could leave
unless they met strict requirements and
those who didn't face a nearly
impassable barrier complete with
floodlights and guard towers were armed
border guards patrolled day and night
with orders to shoot and kill anyone
trying to cross illegally and that's how
it remained for 28 years but change came
in late 1989 Soviet leader Mikhail
Gorbachev had introduced social reforms
meant to relax oppressive practices and
open up discourse between people and
government these changes unintentionally
sparked massive peaceful uprisings
throughout Eastern Bloc countries
including East Germany things had kind
of heated up all summer in 1989
Catherine Baumbach was a young
translator working for the East German
news agency in the world of famous
Monday demonstrations in in Leipzig
actually my college town initially
thousands then tens of thousands to
hundreds of thousands freedom of
expression and freedom to travel were
key demands and pressure on the GDR to
loosen travel restrictions only grew as
neighboring countries particularly
Hungary and Czechoslovakia relaxed their
border laws prompting a mass southward
exodus of East Germans by early November
1989 more than 40,000 East German
refugees had arrived at the West German
Embassy in Prague hoping to travel to
the West the GDR was facing a crisis
there were forces in the government that
realized something had to be done this
was not sustainable so lifting the
travel ban was one way that they thought
they could quell the protests and make
people happy on November
1989 GDR official Gerhard lauter was
tasked with drafting looser travel
regulations meant to be a temporary
pressure release the new rules were
finalized less than a day later and read
private trips abroad can be applied for
without conditions permits are issued on
short notice without conditions that's
the key phrase here this meant the
strict application requirements were
eliminated and anyone who wanted could
leave East Germany and come back that
afternoon the updated regulations were
handed to government spokesmen come to
Chbosky just as he was about to begin a
routine press conference and as we all
know something kind of didn't go quite
right there he didn't have time to
review them before sitting in front of
cameras and as you can see from his
handwritten roadmap of the press
conference he scribbled in a reminder to
announce them at the very end and on
live TV at 6:53 p.m. on November 9th he
read the relaxed travel laws for the
first time out loud as implies nothing
it seemed totally unreal but it was
Scherbatsky saying it was broadcast on
official television so it had to be true
there were people people around me older
colleagues who immediately said this is
the beginning of the end
watch a confucian boskie shuffle his
papers when a journalist asks a simple
follow-up question the thing is if
Chbosky had had time to read the new
rules he might have seen this on the
final page the new regulations were
meant to go into effect the following
day in an orderly manner when the
passport offices were open so close
in particular what happened next can
only be described as a chain reaction by
7:05 p.m. the AP wire had already gone
out GDR opens borders and both East and
West German nightly news reports
announced the stunning policy reversal
these Berliners began gathering at the
wall and security officers tried to let
them through slowly but the final nail
in the coffin came at 10:42 p.m. when
this broadcast triggered a mass rush
he's anointed November stand his tallish
attack did it a hot lead guitarist
Gilligan snaps of Fox agita manga of
mutant the Torah in the mawashi in vital
they actually weren't yet but by this
point there was no going back tens of
thousands of Berliners stormed a wall
saying they heard on the news that they
could cross the outnumber East German
border guards were completely
overwhelmed
somehow they hadn't gotten the message
or they didn't know what to do or they
were afraid who knows but they basically
opened the border and thousands of
people streamed into West Berlin
[Applause]
over its 28-year history at least 140
people died trying to cross the Berlin
Wall November 9th plus unification a
year later it was the most decisive
event in in my life I basically went
from one political system to another and
changes happened very quickly and it
happened unintentionally the result of a
rushed plan and a botched announcement
delivered in a small room at the end of
a boring press conference just a so
forth one procedure
[Music]